Welcome to the lecture series
of the College of Science.
My name is Joaquin Ruiz.
I'm the Dean of the College.
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
Last week we had
a lecture series,
which was really
extraordinary in itself.
It was about mind
and brain, and it was
all about what makes us humans.
This lecture series now on
cosmology is what makes us.
So I hope you enjoy it.
Today's speaker I am really
proud of introducing,
Chris Impey though many
of you may know him.
Before I introduce
Chris, of course
I think we have to recognize
again those folks that
make it free for the rest of
us, and those are the sponsors
of the lecture series.
[AUDIENCE CLAPPING]
But let me now introduce
you to Chris Impey.
Chris is a University
Distinguished professor
whose research interests
are observational cosmology,
gravitational lensing, and
the evolution of structure
of galaxies.
He has 160 refereed publications
and 60 conference proceedings,
and his work has been
supported by $20 million
in grants from NASA and NSF.
He has won 11 teaching
awards, and he
has been heavily
involved in curriculum
and instructional
technology development.
Chris is past President of the
American Astronomical Society.
He has also been a
National Science Foundation
distinguished teaching scholar,
a Phi Beta Kappa visiting
scholar, and the Carnegie
counsel on teachings Arizona
professor of the year.
He has written over 30
popular articles in cosmology
and astrobiology,
and co-authored
two introductory textbooks.
He is the author of two popular
books, "The Living Cosmos"
and "How It Ends,"
and in 2009, he
was elected Fellow of
the American Association
for the Advancement of Science.
In addition to all of
this, instead of sleeping,
Chris regularly
teaches cosmology
to Buddhist monks at the
monastery in the Himalayas,
has played pingpong at Mt.
Everest base camp, and
I have to warn you,
his Scottish accent emerges
after drinking single scotch.
Chris.
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
OK.
I'm really pleased to be here.
So I want to start with history.
A guy gave some amazing
and beautiful story
of the philosophical
and religious traditions
that underpin our
ideas of the universe.
I'm going to give a little
more history leading up
to the idea of the Big Bang.
And the fundamental
dichotomy in this subject
is a profound issue that
it's easy to understand.
It's the distinction between
whether the universe is
finite or infinite.
And that's either
in time or space.
And worrying about
this is essentially
what cosmologists do.
Normal people get
up and they worry
about paying their mortgage,
and paying the college bills,
cosmologists, people
like me, get up
in a cold sweat worrying
about whether the universe is
infinite or not.
Does the universe go on forever
or does it have a limit?
These questions have
been asked for centuries.
Plato's colleague, Archytas,
said, imagine a warrior
with a spear at the
edge of the universe,
and he hurls his spear swiftly.
Do you imagine that
it goes forever?
And into what?
Or does it hit something,
or bounce back?
And in that case,
what's the limit?
So you can see either way
there's a bit of a problem.
It's either infinite, and
what's all that about?
Or there's an end, and
what's the end and what's
beyond the end?
And cosmologists wrestle
with the same questions.
And I'll attempt to
partially answer them today.
When Copernicus replaced
this, the geocentric model,
with the heliocentric model,
it was a revolutionary move.
The word revolution in
our modern sense of it,
as violent political
and social upheaval,
refers to Copernicus's
book on the revolutions.
Because what he did was
not just astronomical,
it was a revolution, a
profound social revolution.
You can imagine
also how difficult
it was when, beyond that,
in the mid 16th century,
Thomas Digges extended
the celestial sphere
to innumerable stars going off
the page in every direction.
Infinite numbers of stars.
This was an
incomprehensible idea.
It got people into trouble.
This is the statue in the
Campo de Fiori in Rome
of Giordano Bruno,
who was burned
at the stake as a pertinacious
and impenitent heretic
by the Catholic church,
for not only believing
in an infinite
universe, but believing
that those innumerable stars
had planets around them
with lifeforms on them,
and perhaps people.
And this was too much to bear.
Cosmology is a
shifting landscape.
The next venture
towards the infinite
was Isaac Newton, who
postulated an infinite universe.
Infinite in extent,
in time, and space.
And this was followed
by Wright, who
imagined infinite inhabited
worlds in this universe.
It's still a difficult
concept, and it's
difficult conceptually.
If you were in a large
forest, every sightline
through the forest
would end in a tree.
In an infinite universe,
every sightline
must end on a point
of light, whether it's
a star or a galaxy.
Since the light from
each star diminishes
as the square of the distance,
but the number of stars
rises by the same factor,
logically the night sky
should be bright-- as
bright as the daytime sky--
in an infinite universe.
This was a paradox that
Newton never resolved.
Not only infinite in light,
but infinite in gravity too,
since that's an
inverse square law.
So it took longer to learn
how the universe works,
and to resolve Olber's paradox,
which, to cut to the chase,
is resolved by the finite age
of the universe and the fact
that it is expanding.
Our sense of the
universe evolved
through the time of
Herschel, making a catalog
of fuzzy objects in the sky.
Another dichotomy
arose as an argument
over whether the Milky Way,
the system of stars we inhabit,
was the whole universe
or whether there
were other Island Universes,
systems of stars like our own.
Herschel managed to
map out the Milky Way
and knew it was vast, perhaps
100,000 light years across.
But at the turn of
the 20th century,
two very different
ideas were in play.
In one of them,
the fuzzy nebulae--
including the Andromeda
nebula, the easiest
to study with big
telescopes-- were hypothesized
to be distant systems of
stars like the Milky Way,
perhaps hundreds of thousands
or millions of light years away.
The countervailing
model, which was actually
accepted through the
beginning of the 20th century,
said that these fuzzy
patches of light
were just regions
of star formation
within our own large galaxy,
which was the universe.
This was resolved
by Edwin Hubble, who
made the breakthrough discovery
by measuring the distance,
astronomically, to
the Andromeda nebula
and a few dozen other
galaxies for the first time.
The method he used involved
isolating variable stars
within the body of the
galaxy and recognizing
that they were identical
to similar variable stars
in the Milky Way.
Nature provides a
linear relationship
between the absolute
brightness, or flux,
from these variable stars
and relates it to the period.
So by measuring the period of
variable stars in Andromeda,
comparing them to local
examples at known distance,
he was able to show that
Andromeda was several million
light years away.
It was an external galaxy.
And by the end of
his career, he had
extended the size of
the known universe
by a factor of thousands.
From a few thousand light
years to a few hundred
million light years.
That's the Hubble revolution.
The second revolution
is to come,
that of the expanding universe.
But before going any further in
talking about a vast universe,
let me remind you, as Guy
did last week, that cosmology
involves assumptions.
We don't know everything.
The first assumption,
very profound,
is that the universe is
in fact comprehensible.
It's not necessarily the case.
In fact, it's difficult to
keep the universe in your head.
Another assumption is that the
universe obeys physical laws.
It's a thing that has
been found magical
to scientists and
mathematicians,
that the universe
is so well described
by simple and sometimes
complex mathematics,
and by a very small set
of physical laws that
seem to apply everywhere.
It didn't have to be that way,
but it seems to be that way.
These physical laws
remind us that our venture
into the universe is incomplete.
We don't know where
this will end.
If we simplistically imagine
that the universe, nature,
consists of things that happen
and things that don't, things
that are and things that
aren't, the theory we have,
being modest,
describes some subset
of the things that
actually happen.
It's not the theory we want.
The theory we want is
the theory of everything.
A theory that describes
everything that
actually is in the universe.
But the danger, of course, is
we don't know how to get there.
And along the way, we
might, in our over-ambition,
end up with a
theory of too much.
And how would we
know the difference?
Another way of looking
at this, and maybe
a little more
profound, is the fact
that we're bounded actually
not by our science,
but or by our imaginations.
And our imaginations are very
supple and very impressive.
So there are the set
of things, for example,
that are possible that
don't actually happen.
That includes everything
that happens in the universe,
plus some things that
break no law of nature,
but don't actually happen.
And if you wonder about the
things that you can imagine,
the imaginable things hopefully
include all the things
that do happen, but
maybe not all of them,
almost certainly include a lot
of things that are possible,
but not all of
them, and includes
a lot of things that
just don't happen,
but they're fun to think about.
Once again, how do we
bound our imaginations
in the universe that
has not yet presented us
with all of its phenomena?
We also assume that the universe
obeys very simple laws that
says effects have causes.
You have to think a bit to
realize how incomprehensible
the universe would be
if causality did not
operate at some level.
Now note that this does
not imply determinism
in the universe.
Laplace famously caricatured
Newton's Law of Gravity
by implying that if we knew
the positions and velocities
of every particle
in the universe,
we could predict the entire
future of the universe
deterministically.
Science is not
deterministic, but causality
is a foundation stone.
Without causality, events
could proceed causes.
Things can move backwards
and forwards in time.
And we know that that
is extremely tricky.
We make another assumption
that is improperly
tested by modern science, which
is that the laws of physics
are the same everywhere.
We do know that the
cosmological principle, which
is the underlying assumption
that the universe is
the same in every direction
and every location,
is true in the sense
of every direction.
Here looking across the sky,
we see roughly equal numbers
of galaxies in each sideline.
But testing it in location
is impossible because
of the finite speed of light.
If the speed of
light were infinite,
we could see the entire
universe as it is now, laid out
before us in its wonderfulness.
But the speed of
light is finite,
and that leads to a
very interesting issue.
The issue of ancient light.
Now cosmologists turn
the lemons into lemonade,
and the fact that light
has a finite speed
becomes an advantage because
it means that distant light is
old light.
The light that you
see reflecting off me
from the stage lights
takes maybe a nanosecond
to reach your eyes.
You can't detect
that difference.
You probably remember
the little time delay
when people talk to the
astronauts at the moon.
That's about a second.
If you're talking about
the sun and some evil alien
civilization squashed
it into a black hole
and extinguished
its light, it would
be eight minutes before
we were the wiser
because that's how long it
would take that information
to reach us.
And it actually makes no
sense to ask of nature,
what is the sun doing now?
What is Sirius doing now?
No, you have to be patient.
You have to wait
those nine years
for the light of that
bright star to reach you.
And by the time you're in
the extra galactic universe,
those light travel times
are becoming interesting.
Far longer than a human life.
Even the nearest galaxy is a
few million light years away,
which means we see it
as it was in the past.
And at the limit of our
telescopes, which I'll get to,
they become time machines.
And that's an extraordinary
thing to be given.
A final assumption is
that our location is not
special in the universe.
And the more general
cultural way of saying that
is that we are not
privileged in any way.
I mean, occasionally it's
hard to get over the fact
that we feel privileged, but
the Copernican revolution,
if it's telling us anything,
is saying, get over yourselves.
Just get over yourselves.
You're not that special,
you're not that important.
Starting with the Copernican
revolution itself,
we have found that we are
not special in our location
in our galaxy, and
our galaxy is not
special in its location
in the universe.
As I'll mention, we
found that were not
even made of the stuff
the universe is made of.
And the universe we
occupy may be one
of a larger set of universes.
And our biology
may not be unique.
There's really nothing that
might be special about us
in a cosmic sense.
But this idea of
light travel time
is critical to understanding
how the universe started,
because it means to look at
all we have to do is look
out further and further.
And so we have
the nearby now, we
have the realm of the stars,
which is quite recent,
maybe human lifetimes.
We have long ago galaxies,
and for the universe itself,
its ancient.
Its looking back to
the dawn of time.
And now you thought
you were going
to go away with just
being participants here,
we're going to have some
audience participation.
Yes, you are part of the show.
You all got a card.
Don't be scared,
it's quite harmless.
We do this all the time.
You have a card.
OK.
There is one way to screw up.
Don't fold the card so
the white points outwards.
So you can fold the
card, the piece of paper,
in half and then half again.
And it doesn't
matter in which order
you do the haves and half
again, as long as the colors are
pointing outwards.
And you will have made a
quadrant piece of paper,
which with one fold,
you can put whatever
ABCD do you want in front.
And so I'm going to
ask you a question,
and you're going to vote,
and the way you vote
is by putting your
answer facing me.
Don't put the answer facing you.
You know what your answer is.
You don't need to
remind yourself.
If this is my answer, I point it
to you, and you point it to me.
OK?
Is everyone clear?
Look, I can come out
here, you know, I'm
not-- if anyone's not clear.
John, are you clear about this?
Gale, do you know
how this works?
You know how this works.
OK.
So if nobody's-- if
someone's not clear,
just tell me and I'll
come back and help them.
But anyway, we're
going to warm up.
And I'm going to
count down to three,
and then we'll flip to
a camera where you'll
be able to see how you voted.
So you have to trust me.
Because otherwise
you have to trust me,
and I'm probably going to lie.
So here's your warm up question.
Yes, it is a very easy question.
And there's no E. There's no
E, so no-- oh, you're too good.
We're not ready with a camera.
I'm going to count
down to three.
You're too good.
But there's no E, so there's
no failing this class.
I'm going to get
my answer ready.
Actually I'm not sure
because I'm finished,
I could still screw up.
So I'm going to give myself
a tentative B, but go ahead.
On a count of three,
hold your cards up
and we'll show
you what you said.
One, two, three.
There you are.
Oh, my goodness, that's a--
we got a few people in there.
There's a-- there's
a few people who
are pretty hard on themselves,
but mostly you're doing well.
OK.
If we go back to-- now I'm going
to ask you a real question.
So this is an analogy question.
The age of the universe
is to a human life
as a human life is to what?
And I'll give you few
seconds to think about it.
Just prepare your answer so
we can do it all together.
And I'll count down.
So we do it all together and
then we'll flip to the camera.
So think about that.
OK, that's enough.
You're all smart, you
can figure this out.
Three, two, one, go.
Very good.
Wow.
So you're right, it's
a fraction of a second.
Human lives are about
a billion times less
than the age of the universe.
Actually, you kind of
know all this stuff.
I think I'm going to quit.
I've heard they're serving
some really good single malts
downtown, so we could all
get out of here early.
But no.
That was good.
So the first lesson on
the age of the universe
is of course the
vastness of time
that astronomers have
indeed pretty much probed.
But let's return to what the
universe is made of before we
go back in time
towards the Big Bang.
Well talk about normal
matter first, the stuff
that we're made of.
99.9% of the universe
is hydrogen and helium.
Rather uninteresting, and
the two simplest elements.
Now, Phil [INAUDIBLE]
in a few weeks
is going to talk
about the 0.1% that's
left, but don't think of that as
a residue that's uninteresting,
because without
that residue formed
in the fiery heat of
stars, we wouldn't be here.
That includes all
the nitrogen, carbon,
and oxygen that life depends
on, the heavy elements.
So that's a critical
part of the universe,
but it's very
important that stars
exist because if stars had
never formed in the congealing
gas of the expanding
universe, the universe would
have stayed hydrogen as helium.
Now you know, I'm a
physicist, I'm not a chemist.
But let me put my thinking
hat on and figure out
what you can make with
hydrogen and helium.
Nothing.
You can't make anything
with hydrogen and helium.
You can make a
hydrogen molecule, duh.
And then you've got
helium, which is inert.
That's really dull.
Would be a dull universe
without stars, don't you think?
That's the normal
matter, that's the atoms.
And look how many there are.
A one with 80 zeros after it.
That's maybe the biggest
true pure number in science,
because that's an
actual number of atoms.
I know, I've counted-- no,
I haven't counted every one.
Nobody has counted
everyone, it's an estimate.
But it's pretty good.
But it's actually eclipsed
by a factor of a billion
by the number of
photons in the universe.
There are a billion photons in
the universe for every atom.
That's an interesting fact,
which will be fully explained,
I think, by Mike
Turner next week,
but I'll allude to where
it may have come from.
Something we need to
explain about the universe,
most of those photons
are unnoticed by us
because they're dim
microwaves that I'll
talk about in a few minutes.
And those atoms, those 10
to the power of 80 atoms,
are agglomerated into 100,000
billion billion stars--
10 to the power of 23--
which typically are
parsed 100 billion per galaxy.
And there are a hundred billion
galaxies, round numbers,
in the visible
universe, the universe
we can see with our telescopes.
So they're, in a nutshell, is
what the universe is made of.
That's a lot of stars
and a lot of galaxies,
and just to put a little forward
light onto Carolyn Porco,
the last speaker in
this series, she's
going to talk about the
proclivity of the universe
for life, and she's going
to talk about the way
we search for life
in the solar system.
Our technology only lets us look
for biology in our backyard.
So far.
But what you should realize
is the cosmic number that
based on the census
of Earth-like planets
with the Kepler
Telescope and what
we know from our backyard
in the Milky Way,
the best guess is that there
are a billion billion Earths
out there.
More or less.
Earth-like.
That is an incredible number.
And so you have to ask
yourself the question,
since life started on
the earth almost as soon
as you can imagine, when
the conditions were really
inhospitable, do
you imagine that all
of those billion billion
Earths out there are sterile
and there's no biology
in any of them?
Or put another way,
how many of them
do you think have spawned
some interesting biological
experiment, perhaps
even eclipsing
the intelligence and
complexity of life on Earth?
Wouldn't that be
nice to find out?
But that's the cosmic context
for life in the universe.
And these galaxies are real.
We can observe them with
the Hubble deep telescope.
The galaxies you see panning
across this tiny region of sky
are all 10 or more million times
fainter than the eye can see.
Each of them is within 10, 5
to 10 billion light years away,
so you're looking
at an ancient light.
And as you look at them,
each of these galaxies
has roughly 100 million earths.
You can imagine the
possibility that
on some of these galaxies
across the eons of time, someone
or something is
looking back at us.
Each fuzzy smudge is a galaxy,
a distant system of stars,
seen with the Hubble
Space Telescope
in the deepest image ever made.
That's the normal
matter, but in a surprise
to astronomy that's now 30 or
40 years old so astronomers have
gotten over their
surprise, the universe
is made of six or
seven times more dark
and mysterious material than
the light and visible stuff
that we're familiar with.
It's called dark matter.
It's seen here, not
because we can see it,
but this is a
computer simulation
where we try and understand
the universe by spooning
dark matter with the appropriate
properties into a computer,
and seeing how it
structures over time.
The dark matter
itself is invisible.
So how do we know it's there?
Good question.
And was answered
painfully by astronomers
over several decades.
We weigh galaxies by
looking at star motions.
Now if you looked at the
motions of stars near the sun,
they're just milling
around randomly
because the little cube
within 100 light years
is partaking in a leisurely
quarter billion year orbit
of the center of our galaxy.
But if you map out the motion
of stars across the entire Milky
Way, you see a
pattern of rotation
which should have a
particular character
if the mass of the
Milky Way is where
you see the light, which
is where the stars are,
which is what you expect.
What astronomers saw, starting
actually 30 or 40 years ago,
was something quite different.
Again, if the galaxy's
mass was really just
where its light was,
then by Kepler's law,
you would expect the velocities
of those peripheral stars
to start to decline because
you've seen past the mass.
Just in the same way that
moving out from the sun,
the velocities of
the planets all
declined to the outer planets.
What was seen was
not that at all.
The velocities
continued high, even
rising beyond the
distance of the sun
to the outer edge
of the Milky Way.
Not only in the Milky
Way, but in every spiral
galaxy ever observed.
This is a universal
phenomena as far as we know.
And the only
sensible explanation
for this in terms of gravity
is that the mass of a galaxy,
if you just look at
its stars, you're
underestimating by a
factor of six or seven.
And that larger factor
additional is dark matter.
The second way we've
measured it very convincingly
is by gravity bending light.
If you look at
the distant galaxy
through a cluster of
galaxies between you
and I-- between it and
us, mass bends light
according to general relativity.
And so the light of
those distant galaxies
is stretched,
sheared, and amplified
into little arcs of light.
It's a very striking phenomenon.
Can't be explained
any other way.
This gravitational
lensing, as it's
called, a prediction
of general relativity
and a confirmation of
general relativity,
is a way of weighing a cluster,
and also individual galaxies.
And it confirms what
motions of stars do,
that galaxies are dominated
by invisible matter.
And the question becomes,
what is the dark matter?
And all I can say at
this point, but we're
optimistic within a
decade we may know,
is play a game of elimination.
First of all, why not question
your theory of gravity?
And people have done
that, to be fair.
The point is that the
gravity law, and that
is Newton's law on large
scales and Einstein's law when
gravity is strong, has
passed so many tests that
were unwilling to throw
it away because then you
throw everything away.
And so the hypothesis has
become that there is a dark form
of material in the universe.
You can only make the
universe in a computer look
like the universe we see if
you put dark matter into it.
So far all we've done
is eliminate things.
Well, black holes are dark,
maybe it could be black holes.
No, because before
you have a black hole,
you have a supernova, and
that's a pyrotechnic display
that would be easy to find.
Maybe they're just
dim normal stars?
No, our stellar senses,
with things like the Hubble,
is just too good.
You can't hide stars in
sufficient quantities,
because remember, you
need five or six times
more than normal stars.
What about things that are just
too low in mass to turn on,
to ignite in fusion and so
they don't shine, so their dim?
Dark things like brown
dwarfs, or even planets,
free floating planets.
Can't do it.
Once again,
gravitational lensing
would find the signature
of those insufficient
if they were in that large
number, and that's ruled out.
And then you can
go all the way down
to mountain-sized
boulders in space,
to things the size of your
fist, to microscopic dust
grains just littering space.
And indeed those things would
be very faint if no nearby star,
hard to see with a telescope,
but those are actually
ruled out because
they would still
be subject to the ambient
radiation of stars,
and they would radiate
in the infrared.
And infrared satellites have
convincingly ruled this out.
If you look at what
we've done, we've
ruled out dark objects all
the way from black holes down
to microscopic grains of dust.
All that's left is subatomic
fundamental particles,
and that's where the game is.
Mike Turner will talk
more about this next week.
Time for a little more
audience participation.
This time on the
size of the universe.
You've done the age, so now
it's time to do the size.
I don't have to explain it.
You know the drill.
So if we're-- let's make
a model of the universe,
just to give you a sense of it.
Centennial Hall is the Milky
Way, 100,000 light years.
Just use your
powers of estimation
to guess how big
the universe is.
And just remember, in
this model, each of you
is standing in for 100
million stars, which
is pretty impressive.
Yeah.
OK.
So you all know-- you're
all quick with this,
so we'll just count it down.
Three, two, one.
Whoa.
Very good.
And you're right.
So the visible universe--
just the visible universe--
would be that enormous size.
And that's sort of
like the Earth--
that's 10 times the
radius of the Earth.
So imagine a volume
which is 1000 times
the volume of the Earth,
filled with things
the size of Centennial Hall.
And that's the observable
universe, pretty well.
OK.
Good.
So I think the message here
is ignominy, to use the word.
Mediocrity.
Whatever.
We're on an average planet
orbiting a midsized star.
Our galaxy is unexceptional.
We're on the periphery
of a kind of mediocre,
not that impressive cluster
in a undistinguished corner
of a ridiculously
large universe.
And so, you know, this
is part of the punchline.
There's you and
there's the universe.
We're insignificant.
Get over it.
Let's go back to the Big Bang.
Enough beating around the bush.
We have expansion.
Hubble's first discovery that
external galaxies [INAUDIBLE]
distant systems of stars
expanding the known universe
would have been enough to make
him the most famous astronomer
of the last century, but he
made a second discovery close
on the heels of his
first discovery,
and that the cosmic expansion.
Hubble observed the
spectrum of galaxies
shown in the visible
spectrum just turning light
into a rainbow, and then
represented graphically
where you track the wavelengths
of the sharp emission
or absorption features
of the elements
that galaxies and
stars are made of.
And when you do that, you find
that the distant galaxies,
the external galaxies
are always shifted.
Very, very occasionally
to the blue,
but almost entirely to the
red, to longer wavelengths.
And sometimes, as in this
case, by a significant fraction
of the speed of light.
So they're moving
away very fast.
Beyond that, he showed
a linear relationship
between the recession velocity,
the speed of moving away--
and its a large number,
1,000 kilometers per second
there-- and the distance.
MPC is megaparsec, that's
three million light years,
so you're going out to
6 million light years.
It's not a very
good correlation,
but that was his first data
and it established the idea
of an expanding universe.
Since then, we've
expanded Hubble's relation
by factors of 100.
Hubble's original relation,
that previous graph,
is the little blue dot that
would fit the origin here.
With modern telescopes, we
now extend the regime out
to 1 and 1/2
billion light years,
and the perfect linear
relationship holds.
The expansion, the cosmic,
linear, smooth expanding
universe is valid on huge
scales of the universe.
And it logically
begs the question,
if everything is moving away
from everything else, what
happens if you run
the clock backwards?
Surely there was a time when
all the galaxies, now further
apart than ever, were
on top of each other.
And since the universe behaves
in some ways like a gas,
the universe must have been
smaller, hotter, and denser.
You also have your first
check on this idea,
because we know how to
measure the age of the oldest
stars in the galaxy.
And on the principle
that you should never
eat anything bigger
than your head,
the universe should not be
younger than the oldest object
that it contains.
So that's a first check on
this expanding universe idea.
For a while it wasn't clear
how well that check worked,
but now it works.
The age of the
universe projected
by running the expansion
backwards in time
is consistent with the
oldest stars we can find.
And the age of the
universe is between 13,
closer to 14 billion years.
And actually now measured
with quite high precision.
So what about this expansion?
How can we understand
this expanding universe?
Because it begs a
question, of course,
is this violating Copernicus?
If everything is
moving away from us,
maybe we're special after all.
I was really getting worried.
You know, you're
all thinking you're
going to have to buy
this crap about us
being sort of insignificant.
No, no.
We're the center.
It's OK.
It's cool.
Well no, we're not.
We're not the center, because
here we are on the red galaxy
and we look at galaxies--
the blue and the red one,
for example.
The blue and the green-- and we
see them moving away from us.
And the more distant
one moves away faster,
as Hubble's law said.
But now translate
your point of view
to the blue galaxy or the
red one, and look around
and you see the same thing.
Every galaxy sees
the same thing.
It's a democracy of viewpoint,
and so no galaxy is the center.
Every galaxy is the center,
no galaxy is the center.
And presumably on this
blue galaxy, not ours,
there is a planet
going around a star
and someone not called Hubble,
who named the law after them.
And they're going to argue with
Hubble when they eventually
meet in whatever afterlife.
No, that was my law,
I saw that first.
Well did you account
for a lookback time
when you say you saw it first?
To describe the
expanding universe,
you have to use general
relativity, which is definitely
a whole different yarn
than Newton's theory, which
is linear space and time.
General relativity accommodate
the idea of curved spacetime,
in fact, demands it, because
matter curves space--
as we saw in the little
animation-- on small scales,
but on the global scale as well.
Here's what the Hubble
expansion looks like.
So now we've got the idea
of curved space in play,
we can use the little model.
There is no sound
on this, is there?
I better do it.
[HISSING SOUND]
That's tiring.
So there are creatures
in this curved,
two dimensional
universe, an analog,
and they will see every other
creature moving away from them.
So there's a Hubble expansion.
Now the key distinction
between terrestrial physics,
the physics we're familiar with,
is that the Hubble expansion
is a cosmological
redshift because it's
the lower situation.
Spacetime itself is
expanding and the galaxies
are like witless, hapless
victims just being pulled apart
by the expanding
fabric of space.
They are not moving
through an external medium,
as in the upper example.
That's a Doppler shift.
This is one of the fundamental
conceptual changes of the idea
that Hubble introduced,
and Einstein really
understood physically.
We're dealing with a
situation where the universe
itself is expanding.
The galaxies are not
moving like shrapnel
through an external medium.
There is no external
medium, it's
space time itself expanding.
And so we have a
universe which may not
have any boundary in space.
And so to answer the Greek
question, all the way
through the ages, does
the universe have an edge?
It need not.
It may only have an edge in
time because of its finite age,
and the distance we can see with
finite lightspeed in that age.
We can't talk about
a boundary in space
and we have not seen one.
The other thing is
that the universe
has no center, logically.
And it doesn't have to be
expanding into anything.
You just have to wrap
your mind around that.
And then the last
weird component
of the universe, which
I'll say not much about.
Mike will say more next
week because we really
don't know much about it
at all, is dark energy.
An entity, an agent of
some kind physically
that is causing the
universe to accelerate.
So I'll briefly talk about it.
It happened because we tried to
trace the expansion rate back
in time with more
distant objects.
When supernova go off
in a distant galaxy,
these three galaxies are three
to five billion light years
away.
And when a single star dies,
it can rival the brightness
of the galaxy, allowing
us-- because these
are like standard light bulbs
when they explode-- to measure
the distance to these galaxies.
This allowed us to
take the linear Hubble
law, the smooth
cosmic expansion,
and project it to even
earlier lookback times.
What we predicted, what
cosmology predicted,
since the universe has mass
and mass will slow down
the expansion, we predicted that
as you go further back in time,
you should see either
constant or faster expansion.
In other words,
the universe should
have decelerated since five or
six or seven billion years ago.
What was observed
with the red data
points was that the universe
was expanding slower
in the past, which implies that
it's accelerated since then.
And that was a
complete surprise.
Because we know of nothing
that should make the universe
accelerate.
And so it leads to the idea of
dark energy, which I will just
introduce and leave
Mike Turner to do
the heavy lifting next week.
He's a theorist
and that's really
one of his main subjects.
And I will say very little
about it for the simple reason
that we don't know what it is.
It's indicated by the
observation I just showed.
It's a repulsive force working
in opposition to gravity.
Its absolute level
of strength is
too weak to be understood
by conventional physics,
the physics of the textbooks
you might have on your shelf.
And that's about it.
It doesn't seem to vary
over time and space,
but that's not been
measured very well.
And that's the third major
ingredient of the universe.
So we end up with a universe
where definitely we're
not the major part.
In the pizza of
the universe, we're
a kind of paltry little
slice that would barely
keep a sparrow alive,
and the dark energy
and the dark matter, the dark
forces that actually govern
the cosmic expansion,
acceleration, and deceleration
or the overwhelming entities.
So let's look back.
Let's see how close to
the Big Bang we can get.
So here we are on
the right hand edge
of the diagram in a big, empty,
cold universe looking back
through time, through
the aging of galaxies
towards the dawn of time
and a much smaller, denser,
and hotter universe.
We simulate this in computers.
Now in the computer, the
expansion of the universe
is done in the computer, and
when I show a simulation,
that expansion
will be taken out.
And so you can see that since
this expanding hot gas is
thinning out,
gravity has to work
against the expanding universe
to congeal stars and galaxies.
In a sense, it's lucky
that it happened at all.
Here's a simulation run
from half a billion years
after the Big Bang
to the present day.
It's a 300 million
lightyear cube.
And you see it goes from an
initially smooth distribution
to galaxies not
randomly distributed,
but strung along sheets
and voids and filaments
of large-- beautiful large
scale structure of galaxies,
which is what we see
in the real universe.
The next one is the
same, but rotating so you
get a sense of the three
dimensional structures that
form.
And these structures
are sculpted
by the single forest of gravity
acting over 12 billion years.
So with our telescopes, here's
how far back we can look.
Our frontier instrument is
still the Hubble Space Telescope
until the James Webb
Space telescope,
which the University of
Arizona has an interest in both
of these telescopes.
And you can see that we're
working our way back to a time
that astronomers call the
dark ages, before there
were any stars or galaxies.
If the universe started hot and
smooth and with no structure,
there must have been
a time before there
was light of any kind, and
that's called the dark ages.
Here's the deepest image
of the sky ever made again.
In this area, [INAUDIBLE] the
sky would be the head of a pin,
and there are about
4,000 galaxies
if you cared to count them all.
And just two weeks ago,
the largest redshift
or most distant
galaxy was observed.
This tiny little smudge
zooming in two steps, which
is seen as it was
13 billion years ago
in a universe that's not
much older than that.
And that's pretty much the limit
of our ground-based optical
telescopes, or space-based.
So we've pretty much
seen to the edge of time,
to the edge of the
visible universe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, that's the story.
But there's more,
it gets weirder.
Because if you look back
more than about five
billion light years,
any two objects in space
were moving apart faster
than the speed of light.
Wait a minute, didn't
Einstein say something
about the speed of light
being an absolute limit?
That's his special
theory of relativity.
You know, he didn't get
exhausted after that,
though that's exhausting enough.
He went on to the
general theory,
which describes the universe.
And the general
theory of relativity
has no speed limit
applied to the universe
and the cosmic expansion.
If you trace the standard
Big Bang model back
for most of the first
half of the universe,
the universe was expanding
faster than light.
Which means that the light
from those distant galaxies,
as it was emitted,
those galaxies
were moving away from
us faster than light.
And it's only
because the universe
decelerated subsequently
that light was
able to eventually reach us.
Now a complication on
that is dark energy,
which is causing the
universe to accelerate.
And that means,
even more weirdly,
that some galaxies
that we've been
able to grasp with
our telescopes
will eventually have their light
taken away from the telescopes
because once more
they'll be ripped
faster than the speed of
light away from our view.
It's pretty weird.
And the implication of
faster than light expansion
of the universe-- and this
is profound and important,
and it's a standard part of
cosmology, not speculation,
not the lunatic fringe
of the subject--
is that the physical
universe, all that there is,
is substantially,
maybe vastly larger
than the observable
universe, what
we can see to the limit of the
Hubble telescope or any other.
In other words, those
100,000 billion billion
stars in 100 billion galaxies
are not necessarily, and very
likely, not all there is.
That's just what we can see.
So let's get back closer.
Let's get real close
to the Big Bang,
and in fact this is
the best evidence
that the Big Bang happened.
So when that person
sort of collars you
in Walgreens or in a
supermarket queue and you
happen to mention, they heard
you talking about the Big Bang
and they say, what's
with that Big Bang thing?
I don't believe that,
that sounds crazy.
You say, no, no, listen.
Let me tell you about
the microwave background.
Because the
microwave background,
now that will convince anyone
that the Big Bang happened.
This is a picture
of the microwave
sky from a satellite,
an exquisite image made
just a year ago, but we've
been trying to gather
this data for decades.
And it's a baby picture
of the universe,
looking far back before the
oldest life in those galaxies.
So we can do much
better with this image,
much closer to the Big Bang
than with visible telescopes.
In fact, in the analogy,
this is like a picture of you
when you were a few hours old.
That's how early it is in
the history of the universe.
It's a remarkable picture
from just under 400,000 years
after the Big Bang, in a 14
billion year old universe.
So you can think of the ratio.
In that time, the universe has
expanded by a factor of 1,000.
It's got 1,000 times bigger,
and 1,000 times cooler.
The physics is
actually quite simple.
And the way to understand why
we can get an image like this
is that if you look at a cloud
in the sky, the edge of a cloud
is not a physical
barrier, it's just
the point in the cloud in which
the density of water vapor
diminishes to the
point that light
travels freely and reaches
your eyes, so you see an edge.
Inside the cloud, there's
still water vapor, but more,
and the light bounces around.
So it was in the universe.
Before 400,000 years
after the Big Bang,
the universe was as dense
as the atmosphere of a star,
and light could
not travel freely.
After 400,000 years, the
radiation travels freely
and we see an image of the
early universe from that era.
Since that era, those
photons, that light,
have been stretched
by a factor of 1,000.
So not only does the expanding
universe carry galaxies away
from each other,
the waves of light
that travel through
expanding space
are stretched by expanding
space by the same factor.
And so visible
light, dim red light
from the very early universe, is
stretched by a factor of 1,000
into feeble microwaves.
And that's what the
satellite is seeing.
Those microwaves are everywhere.
There's a million or so
in every breath you take.
Right now they feel this room.
They're ambient.
Ambient radiation from the
Big Bang in the universe.
Because they're microwaves,
they're not really noticeable.
I've occasionally had
people get worried-- maybe
in that same supermarket queue,
someone gets worried about it.
What?
Do you mean there are
microwaves in space?
I might get sterile.
You know, or something
bad might happen.
And if you do the calculation,
I'll reassure everyone
and, you know, that the
intrinsic radiation, the radio
luminosity of the
microwaves around you
is 10 to the minus 5
watts of radio power.
So it's like a 10 millionth
of a light bulb worth of radio
energy.
It's not going to
sterilize anyone.
And it's not really
very noticeable,
which is why it
was hard to find.
And the Big Bang, because it's
everywhere, is not a place.
There is no place.
It's every place and no place.
It was a time, not a place.
Very zen like, isn't it?
And if you really want
to see the Big Bang,
you don't need a fancy radio
telescope, just take your TV
and tune it between
stations, and 1%
of the speckles on the
phosphor of your screen,
if you have an old
style phosphorus screen,
are interactions of the phosphor
with the microwave background
radiation.
And although your friends
and kids and neighbors
may think you're pretty weird
staring at a screen doing
that, I assure you
that that station,
the Big Bang station
is better than the crap
on all the other channels.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
So we can't really get
close to the Big Bang,
but here's a cool thing that
a researcher in Virginia did.
This is the interactions
of matter and radiation
in the first 10 million
years of the universe
shrunk to 10 seconds and
raised from a deep organ
pitch of a large universe,
infinite large universe,
to audible range.
So it was boosted by 50 octaves.
And this is what the Big
Bang actually sounded like.
You didn't think I was going
to show you the Big Bang.
[WHOOSHING SOUND]
Actually I'm going to--
If we bring the sound up,
I'll do that again
because that wasn't
quite loud enough to hear.
I'm going to rewind a little.
[WHOOSHING SOUND]
So that's a sonification of the
actual, physical interactions
of the first 10 million
years of the universe
shrunk to 10 seconds and
boosted by 50 octaves.
And so now we can look
at the known universe
all the way out from the roof of
the world to the dawn of time.
[AMBIENT MUSIC PLAYING]
So let's go back
as early as we can,
and now I'm moving into the
part where we're not so sure.
The things I've told you so
far are pretty conventional
cosmology, they've been
established actually
in some cases for a few decades
with better and better evidence
and data.
And for people who work on the
very early universe theorists,
not like myself, I use
telescopes, you know,
actually what happens after
the Big Bang is kind of dull.
Like they don't really care.
We're looking back
to the dawn of time
now, even maybe before the
dark ages, if possible.
An enormous success
of the Big Bang model
that's not as well publicized
as the microwave background
is the fact that we
have physics that's
tested in the first three
minutes after the Big Bang.
So a 13.7 billion
year old universe,
we have solidly
tested astrophysics.
Because the amount of
helium in the universe--
remember the universe is
mostly hydrogen and helium--
is too much to have been
produced by normal processes
in 100,000 billion
billion stars.
We understand stars very well.
There is not enough helium
made in all those stars
to make one quarter of the
mass of the universe's helium.
However, the entire
universe three minutes
after the Big Bang
was the temperature
of the center of the sun.
And like the sun, it made
helium and other light elements.
It didn't do it for long
because it was expanding.
The sun is stable.
And in fact not only helium,
but three other light elements
have their abundances
measured in space,
and their abundances of four
different light element species
match a single parameter, a
single quantity in the Big Bang
model, which is the
density of order of matter.
That 4% slice of the cosmic pie.
This is a stunning success
of the Big Bang model
because otherwise you
have to explain where
these light elements came from,
and there's no other mechanism
to explain them.
But the Big Bang
brilliantly explains
something that happened
in the first few minutes.
That's our largest
lookback time where
we have a benchmark in
very understood physics.
However we can trace the
expansion all the way back
on a logarithmic
plot, you can see
going to crazy small
fractions of a second.
And, you know,
there are theorists
who are quite happy to
explore the first fractions
of a second, and
next week you're
going to enter the realm here.
You're going to
enter this realm.
If you ask, where's our
tether, our last tether
on the world of the real,
on the world of the lab?
It's here.
That's the limit of the
Large Hadron Collider, which
for an instant, under very
special circumstances,
can create this incredible
temperature of tens
of trillions of degrees,
10 trillion degrees, which
corresponds to the Big
Bang about a nanosecond
after it happened.
So lab physics can
corroborate the Big Bang
all the way back to here.
Beyond here, or before
here, demons lurk.
And Mike Turner
will tell you all
about those demons next week.
It'll be fun.
And I don't do that.
I'm not a theorist.
So when I try and think
about the singularity,
my head just hurts, or it
explodes, or something happens.
So let me just finish with the
frontiers of the subject, which
is sort of a taster of what
Mike's going to talk about
because he's going to give
full play to dark energy,
to dark matter, to
inflation-- something
I'm barely going to mention--
and talk about where
the limit of our knowledge is.
Because it's still
an exciting subject,
it's not like everything
is written in the textbook.
When you get to the first
fraction of a second,
you recognize unity
in nature symbolized
by the ouroboros, an
ancient symbol found
in almost all human cultures,
the snake that eats its tail.
And it represents the fact
that over these 45 orders
of magnitude of
scale, our best placed
to test the fundamental
theories of nature, of particles
and atoms at the very
high temperatures
is the Big Bang itself.
No batter, no other.
And we can zoom over those
45 orders of magnitude
from the largest
structures we see
into the universe to the
quarks at the heart of an atom.
Here done two seconds
for every power of 10.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[WHOOSHING SOUND]
And it is in fact the case,
if you trace this story back,
there is the fraction of time
when the universe was smaller
than an atom.
And you have to
understand that using
the same physical theories
we use to understand
the interior of an atom.
And there are still
mysteries in that world
because, as you know, there
are four forces of nature.
As you go back in time
towards the Big Bang,
you simulate conditions of
extraordinary temperature
where these forces
become indistinguishable.
They merge together.
And in fact, we are looking
for a unified theory of nature
that deals with the super force
that melts all of these forces
together.
At the moment, our
physics is only tested
to the merger of
electromagnetism
and weak, with hints of what
goes on before because we
can't do better in the lab.
In the Big Bang,
we have witnessed,
or we could witness, the
super force in operation.
And I'll give a taste,
again, of things
that Mike should talk
about more next week,
but the reason why there
are a billion photons,
or several billion
photons for every particle
is that a tiny imbalance
and the forces of nature
early on left us
with, say, 10 billion
and 1 particles for every
10 billion anti particles.
And they all annihilated,
leaving a residue of matter.
So the billion photons we
see cooled into microwaves
represent the
totality of radiation
from this matter, anti
matter annihilation.
And the little residue went on
to become 100 billion galaxies.
This must have been an
amazing thing to witness.
Another thing that--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
I'm glad I wasn't
around, actually.
Another thing that Mike
will talk about next week
is something called inflation.
It's a hypothetical
era-- very early,
look at the crazy small number,
10 to the minus 35 seconds--
when the universe inflated
from many times smaller
than a proton to about
the size of a tennis ball.
That's a nice, familiar
object, a tennis ball.
We can imagine the
universe as a tennis ball.
And we use inflation--
it's motivated
by this merger of
forces as a mechanism--
but we use inflation to
explain why the universe is
so smooth and flat,
which otherwise is not
a feature of the
standard Big Bang.
It's not explained naturally
in the Big Bang model.
What we're really reaching
for is a theory of everything
that incorporates gravity.
Now you know-- this,
you may-- everyone's
entitled to their own
theory of everything.
It's fine.
There can be 1,000
theories of everything.
Let 1,000 flowers bloom.
Now you probably know
that Einstein fruitlessly
spent the last 15 years
of his career searching
for a unified theory that
incorporated gravity.
It's a very hard thing to do.
The current frontier
theory-- which
I will just skate over very
briefly, it's beyond my domain
here, and you'll hear
more about it next week--
is string theory, which
postulates another,
deeper level of structure
beyond the electrons,
protons, neutrons,
and quarks that we're
familiar with in our
standard model of physics.
So these are
extraordinary ideas that
postulate tiny, one dimensional
entities vastly smaller
than a proton, which
compose everything.
Which compose
everything there is.
And they're motivated
by extremely beautiful
but extremely
difficult mathematics.
These theories of
nature only work
when there are about 10 or
11 space time dimensions.
And the mathematics, of
course, is very difficult.
This has not been observed.
It's extremely
hypothetical theorizing
that's reaching for
another level of structure.
If it's relevant
at all, though, it
must be relevant to
the early universe,
as well as to what
matter is made of.
And so we actually are
faced with the probability,
to use the word that's relevant,
that the universe is a quantum
entity.
It upset Einstein
very much, you know.
All that damned quantum jumping.
It spoiled his
idea of God, which
I tell you frankly is the only
I get of Einstein's I never
understood.
He believed in the
same God as Newton.
Causality, nothing
without a reason.
But now one thing led to another
until causality was dead.
Quantum mechanics made
everything finally random.
A thing could be
this way or that way.
The mathematics
deny certainty, they
reveal only
probability and chance.
And Einstein couldn't believe
in a God who threw dice.
He should've come to me.
I would have told him,
listen, Albert he threw you.
Look around.
He never stopped.
Well you've been a good audience
and you've come this far,
so one last little turn
in the rollercoaster
that hopefully doesn't
eject you at a high speed
and a high height.
I'll talk about the
multiverse, which
is a frontier idea based
on the idea of the universe
as a quantum originating event.
Which logically leads to the
possibility of other quantum
events.
In the inflationary idea--
which you will definitely
hear more about if you
go next week, that's
Mike Turner's specialty, one
of his specialties-- inflation
this early epoch of
very rapid expansion
from micro microscopic
scales to the beginning
of a macroscopic scale actually
stretched quantum fluctuations
into ripples that became the
seed for galaxies to form.
So in that microwave
map of the sky
with the red, yellow, and blue
colors, those little speckles
that are about a degree
across in the sky,
if inflation is
correct, the speckles
are quantum fluctuations
boosted to the size of galaxies
that would subsequently evolve
into systems of hundreds
of billions of stars.
Quite a wild idea, isn't it?
And it's the basis for the
idea of parallel universes,
because if you have a set
of quantum fluctuations
originating at the origin
of time and space, then
you have a mechanism where our
inflating bubble of space time
is not the only one.
There can be many.
And because of the random
nature of quantum fluctuations,
those parallel
universes, if you like,
will be randomly different
in their properties.
They won't all be like this one.
How do we understand these
randomly different universes?
Well, we reach
for string theory.
And string theory doesn't
help very much because it's
too difficult to calculate in,
but the best string theorists
will tell you is
that there are 10
to the power 500
different possible vacuum
states in string theory.
And so that is the basis
for the multiverse.
That's plenty of
universes, you know?
I think E.E. Cummings
said, there's
a hell of a universe
next door, let's go.
Well, there's a lot of
universes next door,
except we can't
really reach them.
So quantum fluctuations
and string theory
provide this
context for the idea
that our universe was
not a unique event.
And how can we test that?
Of course that's
the current question
on the plate of cosmologists.
Is this a testable idea?
String theory is
difficult enough to test,
let alone the idea
of a multiverse.
So I won't pretend that
it has been tested,
and I won't even
pretend that it can be.
It's a frontier idea
that we hope maybe
in a decade or so
to be able to test.
And so in this
inflationary model,
different space times spawn
with different laws of physics,
and the idea is that our
universe is quite special
because it was long lived
and it formed stars,
and the stars made
carbon, and the carbon
sat around long enough at
inequitable temperature
to make biology, and then us.
Many of these universes spawning
from different conditions
would be grossly inhospitable.
Universes that had only
anti-matter, or equal
anti-matter and matter.
Universes that lasted a
microsecond and are gone again.
Universes where
there's no causality.
Every imaginable
universe could be there.
And so our universe is perhaps
one of the few hospitable ones
to life in the
multiverse concept.
So the final piece of
audience participation.
I've talked about
the past, and now I
want to ask about the future.
So your last question is--
and you get to choose,
so this is not just
audience participation,
this is you get to tell me
how I should finish the talk.
So if you could choose
the fate of the universe,
I'll give you the options
that physics provides.
The universe could
end as a heat death,
so everything crunches
down matter is obliterated,
not very good news for us.
We won't be here, but
somebody will be here.
There's dissipation and
decay where it sort of coasts
to a halt and entropy takes
over, and matter falls apart,
and you end up with a sea of
low energy photons, neutrinos,
and anti neutrinos.
That doesn't sound very good.
There's cold death, which is
the big rip where everything
dissipates and is
stretched out in a kind
of dissipative cold expansion.
And then, of course, there's
the possibility-- you know,
there is a possibility
that it doesn't end
and it would go on forever.
And so you can tell
me what you prefer.
One, two, three.
Keep them up there so-- oh.
You want it to go on forever.
That's very selfish of you.
I mean, I don't
like to be a downer,
but you're all going to be dead.
It doesn't really matter.
But, but, I don't
want to be a downer.
I'm not going to finish
by being a downer.
So here I'll just summarize
the kind of nasty scenarios,
and because you want the
universe to go on forever.
OK, fine.
Have it your way.
I will tell you the scenario
that cosmologists have come up
based on these multi-dimensional
theories of space time,
so cutting edge, leading edge.
It may not be right, but it's
very comforting, of course.
And these theories not only
have an eternal universe,
but they posit that
the Big Bang was not
the origination of everything.
That the Big Bang was an event
in a series of events taking
place in higher dimensions.
So they finesse not only
the issue of ending,
but the issue of
beginning itself.
It's an eternal universe.
And it works a
little bit like this.
You have to imagine
higher dimension-- they're
reduced into dimensions I can
show on a graph-- you imagine
higher dimensional
membranes, or branes,
as they're called in the jargon,
so these are higher dimensional
spaces, maybe five
six seven dimensions
within which are three
dimensions of space
and one of time are embedded.
And our universe, our
expanding universe
is spawned by the collision
between two higher dimension
branes.
So the energy of
that collision is
what generates the motive
force for the Big Bang.
Subsequently, forces operating
in those higher dimensions
pull the branes back together.
The universe
expands, dissipates,
but then the whole
cycle repeats.
And the time scale
and in the theory's
about a trillion years.
So you have an eternal
universe spawning three
dimensional expanding
universes filled
with matter and radiation
caused by episodes that
occur in higher dimensions,
and collisions of branes,
or even higher
dimension things that
are impossible to visualize.
All of this, all of this around
us, the 100 billion galaxies,
the diversity of
structure of the stars,
the planets, the people
that we haven't yet met,
all of this from
an iota space time.
It's kind of amazing.
And not to pretend that there
aren't some really profound
mysteries, and you'll hear
more about those next week,
but I think every now
and then you step out
of your world and your life and
the things you read every day,
and you feel good because
this cosmology, this idea,
these ideas that are tested in
part of the edifice of science,
part of what we know about
nature, and in a sense
about ourselves because
we're part of this story,
is one of our greatest triumphs.
And that is the end.
[AUDIENCE CLAPPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]